it's the morning this isn't just a look
I'm going for
oh it is I did my makeup hey Jersey look
at this sorry for colorblind you're
missing out on art in real life on the
internet through the computer so it is
Wednesday here my name is grace Helbig
II do not know now you know your life is
different now I'm on my way to go shoot
some podcasts I have very limited time
so I have to make this video kind of
quick and call these great deluxe
fashion choices and I was stumped on
ideas so I went on Twitter and asked you
guys what do you guys want to talk about
today's video so let's see some of your
suggestions ask me what is one my
favorite ways to get suggestions for
videos also it's one of my favorite ways
to shift blame if this video sucks you
did it existentialism and the emptiness
of life pass hats are great hats are
like head shoes in your head try a hat
your favorite TV show as of today I just
finished narcos last night
if you don't know narcos you should know
knockos knockos is a series on Netflix
some fun light-hearted look at drug
trafficking in Colombia it's intense
also it's subtitled so you can't just
passively watch the show and text and
check Instagram you have to read so now
when people ask me like have you read
anything good lately I'll be like yeah
the Netflix series narcos Oh perfect
segue if you guys don't have time to
read things with your eyes you can
listen to books on audible.com I mean
you guys notice already because you
watch YouTube and every youtuber talks
about Auto Blasio Thursday they are
website with audiobooks over 180 that
was an audio book as of now there might
be more after I've made this
announcement - you guys are available on
that site including but not limited to
both my first book grocery bag the art
of pretending to be a grown-up and grab
your file the art of pretending you have
it which are read by me and if you go to
a low hum slash grace you'll get your
first download for free if you love this
inflection in a four-minute video why
not a four-hour audio go to audio comm
such Grace and
on those your first book for free back
to knockos knockos was fantastic it was
intense it was dramatic and it was super
stylish she she she's installed Pablo
Escobar who's the most infamous drug
trafficker at least in all of Colombia
he's a man that's committed so many
crimes in this lifetime but the only law
enforcement officers that should never
attack this man are the fashion police
because wow I reel so well and one more
time Wow who knew Colombia was such
sweater weather survived in college it's
not Jail you can do it
celebrity news okay what's happening in
celebrity news Katy Perry Veals her one
complaint about dating Orlando Bloom um
let me hear about their pain and
suffering so I can feel slightly better
about my own fairy dish my boyfriend
lives in Malibu and getting used to that
drive was like are you kidding me what
kind of life is this Apple product /c a
video see you put a bunch of Apple
products in a video where's the new SIA
video the greatest oh it's from two days
ago god it's so old where are your
children ah is this gonna be stranger
things how did they sleep standing up
like that
there she is Maddy there's some light
contouring waking up at once all dancing
like Maddy
they all know the choreography oh my god
these new set of kids all know the
choreography there's other kids and they
all know the choreography I know this
looks like a dirty thirty trailer but
it's not oh where they come from
Broncos
we went in her mouth oh my god it's like
Magic School Bus these kids are raving
on a Monday oh that girl's yes Mia also
is this easy season three it seemed like
I want a fire party you don't agree
oh gosh well that's some good birth
control so I think we're gonna wrap up
that this video talking about whatever
you guys want to talk about now I'll
just turn into a see a music video
review how fun are you guys like this
kind of stuff let me know I have fun
doing this more casual stuff like
nothing nothing on my channel is formal
but I like doing stuff like this and if
you really liked it subscribe to this
YouTube channel casino why not also
dirty 30 the new movie that myself and
mamrie art and hannah hart have coming
out on september 23rd is available for
pre-order you can click the link below
you can go to dirty 30 movie calm or you
can go to itunes it's all over the place
excuse me discussing I don't know that's
exactly how I drink coffee every time I
drink coffee